- Stay true to myself.
- I've stayed pretty true to
whatever my instincts are.
- You've got to stay true to who you are.
- Be yourself.
- Stay true to who I am.
- To myself, I had to be true.
- Hello believe nation,
today we're going to talk
about how you can stay true to yourself.
And always as you're watching,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the
comments below and put quotes
around it, so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(dramatic music)
- I haven't had any regrets, you know,
and it's sometimes really hard.
I'll tell you a funny story.
I remember right before
I got A Different World,
I auditioned for Blossom.
- Oh.
- Do you remember the TV show Blossom?
- Absolutely, yeah.
- Do you remember her
friend, the young girl?
- [Woman] Her six?
- Her six.
- I auditioned for Six, okay.
And I had my hair up in a little pony tail
with this little jumpsuit.
I looked like I was about twelve.
(laughter)
Got the role, okay.
Got the role to play Six.
And I was like, I was
18, 19 years old then.
I said, I looked at my
agent Nancy Rainford,
I said Nancy, I can't do this.
I just can't do it.
I'm going to be miserable
playing a twelve year old
on this show.
I can't do this.
- [Interviewer] Right.
- And we had to turn it down.
And let me tell you, them
folks were not happy.
It's like who does this
girl think she is, you know,
and that whole thing.
But within two weeks, I
got A Different World.
And that really taught me a lesson,
which was, you know, to really listen to,
and follow my gut, because
everything that shines
isn't gold, you know what I mean?
And so it really taught
me a very valuable lesson
to just stay true to myself.
If there's nothing that I haven't learned
about this business,
it's really about staying
true to why I'm here,
why, you know, I started
acting in the first place
and what's important to me.
And keeping my artistic
integrity, as well as my creative,
my personal integrity.
And that was a big lesson for me.
And let me tell you, that
was not an easy thing
to turn down.
You know, being a young actress,
you got this opportunity
for this series regular.
It's money, you know.
But I just felt deep
down inside, I was like,
something's coming your
way, just fall back.
And then I got to meet,
you know, Debbie Allen.
(applause)
- I was always the class clown,
always kind of weird and shht.
And it's kind of like I've
always been an outcast
cause they never knew me.
I know we're the outcast,
if you listen to the music.
Or just us in general,
like you met me in person,
I'm just serious now, but
I'm always jumping around.
I'm surprised I've sat
down still this long.
We've always been a fkn
outcast, and it's kind of cool,
cause it's really going to
make us great in the future.
At the end of the day,
throughout all the jokes
and bullshht and whatever,
it's always be yourself,
that's one thing that I'm like,
just do what the fk you like.
That's what I try to tell people
is to do the fk they want,
instead of impressing others.
And that's why at the end of the day,
I'm always going to make
the music I want to make.
Like people get so caught
up in fkn making their first
album, like Bastard was pretty successful.
And people are like,
you should try to make
something like that, but I can't.
It's a progression.
I'm in a whole different
frame of mind today.
I'm having a fkn interview right now.
I wasn't having that a year ago, so.
I'm going to make the music
that I want to make now,
that sounds cool to me.
Who knows, I might end up
doing coke and be a drug
addict two years from now
making some off the wall music.
But at the end of the day,
I'm going to fkn like it,
and I think that's one of
the reason people like us.
We do what we want.
- I stayed pretty true to
whatever my instincts are
as an artist.
Sometimes for worse at first,
because I think when you
do something that's out of the norm,
you have to keep doing
it for a little while,
to make it your own norm.
So it's an exciting idea
to me that I could be
putting a record out and being
able to be my own person.
To not have to think
about what I can't say
or can't do because I
don't want to lose peoples'
understanding of what I do
as a convention, you know?
So I'm really excited about
the idea of people going,
oh no, that's him.
That's him, you know.
- You get new video all the time.
- All the time.
So this is actually a
video of a firefighter
rescuing and resuscitating a kitten.
- Yeah, and a video like that
would very easily go viral
around the world, I mean.
- Oh my god, yeah.
- And that's essentially
a commercial for Go Pro.
- Essentially a commercial for Go Pro.
It's a marketer's dream.
And it's all based off
of authenticity, right?
It's our customers
doing interesting things
around the world and they're so stoked
that they're able to finally
self-document these things
that they like to do and
share it with people.
They're so stoked at how
good they look in the video
that when they share the video,
they often give us credit.
My Go Pro ski trip.
My Go Pro day at the park with my kids.
- You're the only CEO
I've ever interviewed
who's used the word stoked.
- Like five million times.
- [Anderson] Five million times, yes.
(laughter)
- Well you know, you've got
to stay true to who you are
and I recognize that my approach to life
and now our company's
approach to life is what
has made Go Pro what it is.
And so there's no reason to change that.
- You have to be authentic.
I mean, you've got no
hope if you try to pretend
to be Reed Hastings or Mark Zuckerberg
or Bill Gates or whoever you want to think
your CEOs are that you've met.
You know, that is crazy.
And you've got to really get
comfortable with yourself,
your strengths and weaknesses.
People are inspired by authenticity
and I'm just surprised how many people
feel like they're acting or try to act.
And you may be a really
quiet person and that's fine.
But if you have that
fierce will, that desire
for the institution,
the company to be great,
and your own role in that is secondary,
and you authentically
express that in whatever ways
you do, then you'll be greatly accepted.
Okay, and so that's all it
takes, is to be authentic
and not try to be something
else, and to fundamentally
care at your core about
what's good for the company.
And if everybody knows,
and you act in the notion
of what's good as best as
your judgment can tell,
what's good for the
company, they will see that.
And people will follow you.
And they won't be cynical.
It's when you hide things,
it's when you pretend,
that you lose trust very quickly.
- Man you just got to stay
real to yourself, you know,
not ever try to follow the trends.
That's when you get
lost in the sauce, man,
you got to do what you feel
man, and be creative in it.
Don't be scared to be yourself,
always keep that faith.
I've been in the darkest times of my life,
when I didn't know what
was going to happen,
and I was flat broke.
Anything you can think of
man, I done been through it.
You got to be strong
enough to make it through.
And it just makes it that much sweeter,
when everything starts going right.
- [Narrator] When she was 17 years old,
Stephanie got her high school
diploma and left the nuns
to join the prestigious
Tisch School of Arts,
a school entirely dedicated
to artistic disciplines.
She took numerous classes
such as art story,
music, theater and dancing.
- I was really blessed
and lucky to get in.
I got in very early.
I was 17 and I was one
of 20 people in America
that got into the school early.
And I was really happy and
excited and I just felt
like all my dreams were coming true.
And it was a wonderful school,
but it was very factory like.
Not in the Warhol factory like way,
more like a sausage link factory,
- Okay.
- where everyone was taught
the same sorts of things
and I think what I didn't
like about the school
was I felt that they wanted
us all to be the same
and possess the same skills.
And I had something very
different inside of me.
- You think the secret to
your success is actually
that you are in many ways, and
the way you lead your life,
your tastes are quite
average, middle of the road,
the kind of stuff the
mass market would like.
- Sure, absolutely right.
And I don't think you can make records.
I don't think you can
make TV shows properly
unless you can sit there
as a listener or a viewer.
You can't guess what people like.
It would be like guessing
what you want for dinner.
It's impossible.
I can tell you what I want.
So I base everything on my own tastes.
And I have fairly broad, you know,
I'd say, quite simple tastes.
- I mean as terrible as it
is, the kid who had the girls
in the neighborhood and
who had the nicest car,
sold the most drugs, you know.
There wasn't really
anybody I could look up to
that was from my situation
that really made something
of themself.
That's why I feel it's
so important to stay true
to who I am and where I'm from, you know.
Because kids like myself
do look up to me, you know.
And I came through it the right way.
So it really, you know, gives
them something to look at.
And something to work for, you know.
And that's why I've
accomplished really everything
that I've set out to do.
But to just stop and
not stay on that mission
I think would be wrong too.
Because things are still gettin' worse,
you know what I'm saying?
- Which one of you motherfkers
is coming here to say.
(laughter)
You didn't think I was
going to do it, did you?
You thought, oh he's on CNN,
I know he ain't going to
say motherfker.
(laughter)
I fooled you. I fooled you.
To thine own self be true.
So to myself, I had to be true.
I'm not going to litter it.
Litter my conversation with motherfkkr,
as I usually do, if you
know anything about me.
I'm going to limit 'em.
Maybe 12, 13 mutherfkers
through the whole thing,
because I would like
possibly to get a few seconds
on CNN.
(laughter)
But if I don't make it, fk it.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I'd love to know what did you think.
What was your favorite clip?
What was the single biggest
message that you learned
from this that you're going to immediately
apply to your life or your business.
Leave it in the comments below.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Also I'm curious how are you staying true
to yourself.
What are some of the
things that you're doing
in your life consistently to stay true,
to stay authentic.
Leave it in the comments.
I'm going to join in the discussion.
Finally, I want to give
a quick shout out to
Obtain Eudaimonia.
It's a YouTube channel
run by an awesome guy
named Adam, who recently
made an animated book
summary of my book, Your One Word,
that I really really appreciate it.
So go check out his channel as well.
- [Adam] His book
explains the secret to how
one word can transform
you and your business.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love. I'll see you soon.